I'm Jenna Fisher and I'm Angela Kinsey. We were on The Office together and we're best friends. And now we're doing the Ultimate Office rewatch podcast just for you. Each week we will break down an episode of The Office and give exclusive behind-the-scenes stories that only two people who were there can tell you. We're The Office, ladies. Ooh, Angela, we have a good episode today. It is so good.
我是珍娜·费舍，我是安吉拉·金赛。我们曾一起出演《办公室》，我们是最好的朋友。现在，我们正在为你制作终极《办公室》重温播客。每周，我们都会剖析《办公室》的一集，并分享只有身临其境的两人才能告诉你的独家幕后故事。我们是《办公室》女士。噢，安吉拉，我们今天有一集很棒的剧集。真的太棒了。
It's so simple, so wonderful, so much tension, conflict, little bit of drama is all there and some laughs. It is called Did I Stutter? It is season four, episode 16, written by Brent Forrester and Justin Spitzer and directed by Randall Einhorn. We got a lot to cover. I say get into that summary, lady. Here it is.
它如此简单，如此精彩，充满了张力、冲突，还有一点点戏剧性，当然还有笑声。这一集叫《我结巴了吗？》（Did I Stutter?）。这是第四季第16集，由布伦特·福雷斯特和贾斯汀·斯皮策编剧，兰德尔·艾因霍恩执导。我们要讲的内容很多。女士，开始讲梗概吧。就是这个。
Stanley challenges Michael's authority during a conference room meeting, leaving Michael speechless. Mm-hmm. Later, Michael responds to Stanley's insubordination by attempting to scare him into an attitude adjustment with a fake firing. What is with Michael and the fake firings? I don't know. He thinks it's like a go-to.
斯坦利在会议室会议期间挑战了迈克尔的权威，让迈克尔哑口无言。嗯哼。后来，迈克尔试图通过假装解雇来吓唬斯坦利，以纠正他的态度，以此回应斯坦利的抗命。迈克尔和假装解雇是怎么回事？我不知道。他觉得这是他的杀手锏。
I mean, it did not go well with Pam. No, he should have abandoned this whole idea back then. Yeah. But he's still doing it. Meanwhile, Dwight decides to buy Andy's car at a discount only to immediately flip it for more money. Mm-hmm. So shrewd.
我是说，这对帕姆来说效果并不好。不，他当时就应该放弃这个主意。是的。但他还在这么做。与此同时，德怀特决定以折扣价买下安迪的车，然后立即转手卖出以赚取更多钱。嗯哼。真是精明。
Did he shrewd it? He shrewd it. Pam has to deal with the unexpected inconvenience of wearing her backup glasses to work after spending the night at a friend's house. Her backup glasses from junior high? Perhaps. I'll have a lot to share about that. I bet.
他精明了吗？他确实精明。帕姆在朋友家过夜后，不得不面对戴备用眼镜上班带来的意外不便。她初中的备用眼镜？也许吧。关于这一点我有很多要分享的。我敢打赌。
I bet. All right. Fast fact number one, we're going to talk a little bit about the inspiration for this episode. We had a fan question from Bianca Oh and Katie W. They wanted to know who came up with the idea for Stanley to sass Michael. It was me. No, I'm kidding.
我敢打赌。好了。第一个速记事实，我们要谈谈这一集的灵感来源。我们收到了来自比安卡·奥和凯蒂·W的粉丝提问。她们想知道是谁想出了让斯坦利对迈克尔无礼的主意。是我。不，我开玩笑的。
Well, Angela, you do love a sass. I love the sass. Well, we traded messages with writer Brent Forrester about this episode and he told us he remembered being very excited when Greg assigned them the script because it was the biggest Stanley story he had ever done at that point. It was really the first time that Stanley had ever been the sole antagonist in a Michael story. I remember we were all so excited for Leslie, just as actors, to be able to have that big
好吧，安吉拉，你确实喜欢无礼。我喜欢这种无礼。好吧，我们和编剧布伦特·福雷斯特就这一集交换了信息，他告诉我们，当格雷格把剧本交给他们时，他记得非常兴奋，因为这是他当时写过的关于斯坦利最大的故事。这确实是斯坦利第一次在迈克尔的故事中成为唯一的对手。我记得我们当时都为莱斯利感到非常兴奋，作为演员，能够有那个巨大的
moment with Michael and to go head to head with Steve, that was like, you hoped for that, right? Oh, yeah. This was huge. Brent remembers Greg told him with great delight what the game of this episode was. It should be this, Michael is an overpowering boss to everyone in the office but is totally unable to stand up to one person, Stanley. No one ever dares to challenge Michael this blatantly, so when Stanley snaps at him, Michael
与迈克尔对峙的时刻，并与史蒂夫正面交锋，那是你所期待的，对吧？噢，是的。这太重要了。布伦特记得格雷格非常高兴地告诉他这一集的精髓是什么。应该是这样的：迈克尔在办公室里对每个人都是一个盛气凌人的老板，但完全无法应对一个人，那就是斯坦利。没有人敢如此公然地挑战迈克尔，所以当斯坦利对他发火时，迈克尔
just has no playbook for dealing with it. He said that Mindy referred to this as reversal of status comedy and it was the first time Brent had ever heard that term. Mindy, you're so smart. I know, right? I remember doing Commedia Del Arte in Thea to School, Angela. No, here we go. Did you ever do Commedia?
根本没有应对的剧本。他说敏迪把这称为“地位反转喜剧”，这是布伦特第一次听到这个词。敏迪，你太聪明了。我知道，对吧？我记得在戏剧学校做过即兴喜剧，安吉拉。不，我们要开始了。你做过即兴喜剧吗？
No, Jenna, I did my improv and my stand up and my sketch comedy, so just let's hear it. Well, it's really very interesting because Commedia dates back to long, long ago and it is really all about status and you're constantly switching status between these archetypal characters and this has some real Commedia elements for all you theater nerds out there, this reversal of status comedy. No, it's fantastic. I mean, even in improv, we would make someone, when you walk on stage, choose status, high
没有，珍娜，我做过即兴表演、单口相声和素描喜剧，所以让我们听听吧。好吧，这真的非常有趣，因为即兴喜剧可以追溯到很久很久以前，它实际上完全是关于地位的，你不断地在这些原型角色之间切换地位，对于你们这些戏剧迷来说，这确实有一些真正的即兴喜剧元素，这种地位反转喜剧。不，这太棒了。我是说，即使在即兴表演中，我们也会让某人在走上舞台时选择地位，高
or low. And if you constantly played high status, because some people it's their go-to in comedy, our teacher would make you reverse it and play low status. It was always a really cool exercise. Okay, getting a little nerdy. Okay, we can move on. No, I love that we're nerding out on status comedy. Guys, watch comedy shows and look for status and reversal of status.
或低。如果你一直扮演高地位，因为有些人这是他们在喜剧中的杀手锏，我们的老师会让你反转它，扮演低地位。这总是一个非常酷的练习。好吧，有点书呆子气了。好吧，我们可以继续。不，我喜欢我们对地位喜剧进行书呆子式的探讨。伙计们，看喜剧节目时要寻找地位和地位反转。
That's your homework. We're making your television viewing homework now. You're welcome. We're giving you homework. Fastback number two, Brent told us that this episode produced a mantra for the writer's room and a standard for which all episodes would now be held. What? Here were the three words that applied to this episode that they believed make a great
这是你们的家庭作业。我们现在把你们的电视观看变成了家庭作业。不客气。我们给你们布置了作业。第二个速记事实，布伦特告诉我们，这一集为编剧室产生了一个口号，也是所有剧集现在都要遵循的标准。什么？以下是适用于这一集的三个词，他们认为这造就了一集伟大的
office episode. Small, real, relatable. Brent said by normal TV standards, almost nothing happens in this episode. Stanley insults Michael. Michael doesn't know how to respond. He said on any other show, this would have been considered a totally insufficient plot for 30 minutes of TV, but he said at this point in the series, they were so confident in the characters and their dynamics that they fully committed to this very subtle interpersonal
《办公室》剧集。小巧、真实、可感。布伦特说，按照正常的电视标准，这一集几乎什么都没发生。斯坦利侮辱了迈克尔。迈克尔不知道如何回应。他说在任何其他节目中，这都会被认为是一个完全不足以支撑30分钟电视节目的情节，但他说在剧集的这一点上，他们对角色及其动态非常有信心，以至于他们完全致力于这个非常微妙的人际关系
story and they wrote this slogan in the writer's room, small, real, relatable. And he said that he believes that this is the signature of the office at its best. I agree. I always love those types of episodes. I mean, I know it comes before this one, but I felt like healthcare was in that vein. You know? Yes. But yeah, I love small, real, relatable.
故事，他们在编剧室写下了这个口号：小巧、真实、可感。他说他相信这就是《办公室》处于最佳状态时的标志。我同意。我一直喜欢这类剧集。我是说，我知道它在这一集之前，但我感觉《医疗保健》那一集也是这种风格。你知道吗？是的。但是，是的，我喜欢小巧、真实、可感。
I love that kind of comedy. Mm-hmm. All right. Fastback number three, Angela, Pam's glasses. Oh, yeah. We got a lot of mail. Abby S and Amy G want to know, Jenna, is your eyesight as bad as Pam's? And then Cat F, Jessica M and Rachel G want to know how many pairs of glasses were given
我喜欢那种喜剧。嗯哼。好了。第三个速记事实，安吉拉，帕姆的眼镜。噢，是的。我们收到了很多邮件。艾比·S和艾米·G想知道，珍娜，你的视力和帕姆一样差吗？然后凯特·F、杰西卡·M和瑞秋·G想知道这一集提供了多少副眼镜作为选择。
as options for this episode. I remember when we were filming this, at that time, you didn't need glasses. You had great eyesight. Yes, that's right. I did not wear glasses. I do now, but I didn't then. Those are totally fake glasses. Phil Shea came on over with his tray of frames.
我记得我们拍摄这一集的时候，那时你不需要眼镜。你的视力很好。是的，没错。我那时不戴眼镜。我现在戴，但那时不戴。那些完全是假眼镜。菲尔·谢带着他的镜框托盘过来了。
Greg was there and we went through and I had to put them on and we just talked about which ones did we like. We did discuss, Angela, that these were frames that dated back to maybe like years for Pam, like you said. Are these her junior high glasses? Well, you said something interesting on the DVD commentary for this episode. You said you gave yourself your own little actor backstory, right, that didn't exist on the page, hadn't been discussed with the writers.
格雷格也在那里，我们浏览了一遍，我不得不戴上它们，我们只是讨论了我们喜欢哪一副。我们确实讨论过，安吉拉，这些镜框可以追溯到帕姆的几年，就像你说的。这是她初中的眼镜吗？好吧，你在这一集的DVD评论中说了一些有趣的事情。你说你给了自己一个小小的演员背景故事，对吧，这在剧本上不存在，也没有和编剧讨论过。
And for you, these glasses were the pair that Pam leaves in the glove box of her car for just in case. Yes. So here's the crazy thing about these glasses. Greg really, really wanted for my eyes to look super giant when I put on the glasses. But in order for that to be true, they would have had to put a true prescription in the lenses to magnify my eyes. And I said, but then I wouldn't be able to see all day.
对你来说，这些眼镜是帕姆放在车里手套箱里的那副，以防万一。是的。所以关于这些眼镜最疯狂的事情是，格雷格非常非常希望我戴上眼镜时眼睛看起来超级大。但要做到这一点，他们必须在镜片中加入真正的度数来放大我的眼睛。我说，但那样我整天都看不清东西了。
Right. But listen to what Greg said. Greg said, well, here's what we'll do. We'll give you contact lenses to degrade your vision and then correct your vision with the glasses. Greg, what? And I said, that sounds like a lot of effort for these few scenes where Pam wears her glasses. I've never worn contacts before.
对。但听听格雷格说了什么。格雷格说，好吧，我们这样做。我们给你戴隐形眼镜来降低你的视力，然后用眼镜矫正你的视力。格雷格，什么？我说，对于帕姆戴眼镜的这几个场景来说，这听起来需要付出很多努力。我以前从没戴过隐形眼镜。
This sounds like it has the potential to be a real disaster. And possibly damaging to my future eyesight. So I told this to Lee as we were watching the episode. I said, can you believe that Greg wanted me to wear like contact lenses and then glasses? And Lee said, oh, that would have been funny. Greg was right. You should have done it. Oh, Lee.
这听起来有可能是一场真正的灾难。而且可能会损害我未来的视力。所以我看这一集时把这件事告诉了李。我说，你能相信格雷格想让我戴隐形眼镜然后还要戴眼镜吗？李说，噢，那会很有趣。格雷格是对的。你应该那样做的。噢，李。
And I was like, oh, Greg, we'll be so happy to hear that because everybody poo pooed this idea like props, hair and makeup, production. Everybody was like, Greg, the potential for mishap with this idea is too great. We can't have it. So Greg was very reluctant to let it go, but he did. He was like, all right, fine, fine. So I think Greg would be really happy to know that my husband backs up his idea. Well, I have a few more tidbits about Pam's glasses, but I will sprinkle them into the
我当时想，噢，格雷格，听到这个他会很高兴的，因为每个人都对这个想法嗤之以鼻，比如道具、发型和化妆、制作部门。每个人都说，格雷格，这个想法发生事故的可能性太大了。我们不能这样做。所以格雷格很不情愿地放弃了，但他还是放弃了。他说，好吧，好吧，好吧。所以我认为格雷格如果知道我丈夫支持他的想法会很高兴的。好吧，关于帕姆的眼镜我还有一些花絮，但我会把它们撒在
episode as we say, and that finalizes my fast facts, lady. Well, I have two things to share. First of all, little tidbit from the DVD commentary, Randall Einhorn, who directed this episode, said that the editors assembly cut came in at 41 minutes, and then he took that 41 minutes and he got it down to 31 minutes for his director's cut, 31. He didn't want to lose any more, and they had to get it down to 22 minutes to air it on NBC. So there are a ton of deleted scenes, but in addition to that, there's all these other
剧集中，正如我们所说，这就是我的速记事实的结尾，女士。好吧，我有两件事要分享。首先，来自DVD评论的一个小花絮，执导这一集的兰德尔·艾因霍恩说，剪辑师的初剪版时长为41分钟，然后他把那41分钟缩减到了31分钟，作为他的导演剪辑版，31分钟。他不想再删减了，但他们必须把它缩减到22分钟才能在NBC播出。所以有很多删减片段，但除此之外，还有所有这些其他的
scenes that they didn't even get to put in the deleted scenes. There's more. Wow. Yes. And Jenna, here's my big thing I wanted to share with you. As I was prepping for the podcast, I found my shooting draft of Did I Stutter? What? I found the script with all of those lost scenes.
场景，他们甚至没能放进删减片段里。还有更多。哇。是的。还有珍娜，这是我想和你分享的大事。在为播客做准备时，我找到了《我结巴了吗？》的拍摄草稿。什么？我找到了包含所有那些丢失场景的剧本。
Yes. And some we actually shot. They're not even in the deleted scenes. They're out there somewhere, but I found my shooting draft and there are some really hilarious discrepancies that I am going to share with you. There is a Jim Pam moment that is going to make your mouth drop, but I am going to sprinkle these in. I'm so excited.
是的。有些我们实际上拍了。它们甚至不在删减片段里。它们在某个地方，但我找到了我的拍摄草稿，里面有一些非常搞笑的差异，我要和你分享。有一个吉姆和帕姆的时刻会让你大吃一惊，但我会把这些撒进去。我太兴奋了。
I had my shooting draft. I am so jealous. I couldn't believe it. I can't wait. So now with that knowledge, I want you to know that we filmed this episode starting March 31st of 2008. We got an email from Kent Sabornack that said, Hey, you guys, just so you know, while we're filming Did I Stutter, Canadian Entertainment Tonight is coming by the set to do interviews
我有我的拍摄草稿。我太嫉妒了。我简直不敢相信。我等不及了。所以现在有了这些知识，我想让你知道我们是从2008年3月31日开始拍摄这一集的。我们收到了肯特·萨博纳克的一封邮件，上面说，嘿，伙计们，只是让你们知道，在我们拍摄《我结巴了吗？》的时候，加拿大《娱乐今晚》要来片场做采访
in the warehouse and they're going to get B-roll in the main bullpen. So we had Canadian E.T. here the week of Did I Stutter. Amazing. I love how you save every freaking email, Angela. It is so cool and really paying off. I'm just a packrat. I'm a digital packrat and a real life packrat. Well, let's take a break because when we come back, we've got a lot of stuff.
在仓库里，他们要在主办公区拍摄花絮。所以我们在《我结巴了吗？》那一周有加拿大《娱乐今晚》在这里。太棒了。我喜欢你保存每一封该死的邮件的方式，安吉拉。这太酷了，而且真的很有回报。我只是个囤积狂。我是个数字囤积狂，也是现实生活中的囤积狂。好吧，让我们休息一下，因为当我们回来时，我们有很多东西要讲。
All right, well, we are back. Michael burst into the bullpen with all of this excitement because you guys, there is wet cement in the parking lot. And this is a lifelong dream of his. He's got to do something, write something. What is he going to do? And Jenna, when I rewatched this, I started laughing because I remembered how hard Phyllis kept breaking.
好了，我们回来了。迈克尔兴奋地冲进办公区，因为伙计们，停车场里有湿水泥。这是他一生的梦想。他必须做点什么，写点什么。他要做什么？而且珍娜，当我重温这一集时，我开始笑，因为我记得菲利斯一直笑场笑得有多厉害。
How hard we all kept breaking at Phyllis. Breaking. Yes. Because she has an idea for Michael of what he could write in the cement. Oh, but she can't remember it. What was it again? And Michael's going, come on, come on, come on, go, go. And watching Phyllis trying not to laugh, like fighting it so hard, we were all cracking
我们所有人在菲利斯面前笑场笑得有多厉害。笑场。是的。因为她对迈克尔在水泥地上写什么有个主意。噢，但她记不起来了。那是什么来着？迈克尔说，快点，快点，快点，走，走。看着菲利斯努力不笑，就像在极力克制，我们所有人都笑得
up. And if you go to 37 seconds, you can see Rain and John smiling really big because we had all just been laughing. Well, I just think it's very funny that last week Michael got gum in his hair because he found something in the parking lot. And now I mean the cement, the parking lot has been a real source of excitement for him lately. And trouble.
前仰后合。如果你看到37秒，你可以看到雷恩和约翰笑得非常灿烂，因为我们刚才都在笑。好吧，我只是觉得很搞笑，上周迈克尔因为在停车场发现了什么东西，头发里粘了口香糖。现在我是说水泥，停车场最近对他来说真的是兴奋的源泉。还有麻烦。
I kind of just want to say, Michael, get out of your car and go straight inside. Exactly. Somehow Kelly suggests via Pam that Michael put his hand prints. Pam translates Kelly. Yes. Pam speaks Kelly for Michael. But Jim one ups it and says you should put your face in the cement. Oh, ding, ding, ding.
我只想说，迈克尔，下车直接进去吧。确实。不知何故，凯莉通过帕姆建议迈克尔把手印印上去。帕姆为凯莉翻译。是的。帕姆为迈克尔翻译凯莉的话。但吉姆更胜一筹，说你应该把脸印在水泥里。噢，叮，叮，叮。
Michael is so excited. This is what's going to happen. And so much went into this one gag. Oh, yes. This simple sentence in the script was like a whole production. We got some fan questions from Anna V, Abby M, Sonya C, and Gabby C. Please give us all the details about this hilarious cold open. Did Steve really put his face in cement?
迈克尔太兴奋了。这就是要发生的事情。为了这一个梗，投入了太多。噢，是的。剧本里这句简单的话就像整个制作一样。我们收到了一些来自安娜·V、艾比·M、索尼娅·C和加比·C的粉丝提问。请给我们关于这个搞笑开场的所有细节。史蒂夫真的把脸放进水泥里了吗？
How many times did he have to do it? Well, it was not actual cement. Kent Sabornak told me that they had an outside prop house make an organic mixture to look like cement. It was made out of water and some ground oatmeal and a few other ingredients to create a wet cement look. Jenna, I remember touching it and it kind of felt like a putty squishy. Yeah.
他不得不做多少次？好吧，那不是真正的水泥。肯特·萨博纳克告诉我，他们让外面的道具公司制作了一种看起来像水泥的有机混合物。它是由水、一些磨碎的燕麦片和其他几种成分制成的，以创造出湿水泥的外观。珍娜，我记得摸过它，它摸起来有点像油灰，软绵绵的。是的。
Kent said that we put that Vaseline all over Steve's face partially so that we would have quick cleanup and we could do multiple takes. And guess what? It wasn't Vaseline. The container he's holding says Vaseline, but Vaseline is too thick. So it was actually KY Jelly. I remember that. Yes.
肯特说，我们在史蒂夫的脸上涂满了凡士林，部分原因是为了快速清理，我们可以多次拍摄。你猜怎么着？那不是凡士林。他拿着的容器上写着凡士林，但凡士林太厚了。所以实际上是KY润滑剂。我记得那个。是的。
And then they saran wrapped Steve's head and put this like really big rubber band around it and then stuck a straw in there. Yeah. Guys, Steve is a trooper. Oh, yeah. Thankfully, Randall Eindhorn shares that we got this in one take. So he only had to do that one time. And when Dwight says, force it in as deep as you can, Steve improvised, that's what
然后他们用保鲜膜包住史蒂夫的头，在上面套了一个非常大的橡皮筋，然后插了一根吸管进去。是的。伙计们，史蒂夫是个硬汉。噢，是的。谢天谢地，兰德尔·艾因霍恩分享说我们一次就拍成了。所以他只需要做那一次。当德怀特说，尽可能深地按进去时，史蒂夫即兴发挥说，那是她说的。
she said. I remember that. And none of us laughed. Thank God. We couldn't. There was no way we were going to ruin that. No. Steve had been like prepped forever with saran wrap on his head.
我记得那个。我们谁也没笑。谢天谢地。我们不能。我们绝不可能毁掉那个。不。史蒂夫头上包着保鲜膜，已经准备了很久。
We were not going to ruin that take for him. We all wanted it to be done in one take for him. Oh, yeah. Well, Jenna, at one minute, 35 seconds, we all help Michael up from the ground. And there was absolutely no way they could crop out my belly. And I am full pregnant in the shot. It is hilarious to me. I couldn't believe it.
我们绝不会为他毁掉那次拍摄。我们都希望他能一次拍成。噢，是的。好吧，珍娜，在1分35秒，我们都扶迈克尔从地上起来。他们绝对没法把我的肚子剪掉。我在镜头里是完全怀孕的状态。这对我来说太搞笑了。我简直不敢相信。
I laughed out loud when I saw it. There was just no way. It's a split second, but my big old belly is right there. Also, Angela, we have a fan catch from Yonina L at one minute, 26 seconds. She would like to know, are you covering your mouth to stop from laughing? She caught you. Probably. I knew I couldn't ruin this take.
我看到的时候大笑出声。根本没法剪掉。那只是千分之一秒，但我那大肚子就在那里。还有，安吉拉，我们有一个来自约尼娜·L的粉丝捕捉，在1分26秒。她想知道，你是在捂着嘴防止笑出来吗？她抓到你了。可能吧。我知道我不能毁掉这次拍摄。
We got a laugh catch and a belly catch in one scene. Oh, yeah. In one scene. Well, after he has placed his face in the cement, Michael has a wonderful talking head. And he just wants you to know that today wasn't just about him. It's about his grandkids, his great-grandkids. They can come back in a hundred years and he can say, look kids, your daddy left that face hole.
我们在一个场景里既抓到了笑场，又抓到了肚子。噢，是的。在一个场景里。好吧，在他把脸放进水泥里之后，迈克尔有一个精彩的采访。他只是想让你知道，今天不仅仅是关于他。这是关于他的孙子、曾孙。他们可以在一百年后回来，他可以说，看孩子们，你们的爸爸留下了那个脸洞。
And that's really the gift you want to give your kids and grandkids, right? It's a face hole. Yeah. Look kids at my face hole. All I could think about was the number of people who were going to trip in that face hole as they left the building. It's just going to become like a rain puddle. Yeah.
而这确实是你想要给你的孩子和孙子们的礼物，对吧？这是一个脸洞。是的。看孩子们，我的脸洞。我能想到的只有有多少人会在离开大楼时被那个脸洞绊倒。它只会变成像一个雨水坑。是的。
Oh, Michael. Well, now we're into the episode, Angela and Andy are doing mad libs. In the kitchen. Yeah. Angela is delighted to be spending this time with Andy. She's having the best time. Well, I think what we learn in this scene is that Angela loves a mad lib. Mm-hmm.
噢，迈克尔。好吧，现在我们进入了这一集，安吉拉和安迪在厨房里玩疯狂填词游戏。嗯。安吉拉很高兴能和安迪共度这段时光。她玩得很开心。好吧，我认为我们在这一场景中学到的是，安吉拉喜欢疯狂填词游戏。嗯哼。
Who would have thought? I don't know if it necessarily is Andy that she's delighted by or just the idea of a mad lib. Maybe a little of both. Maybe. So I went to the script, Jenna, I went to my shooting draft to see if this scene was written the way we did it. It is up until one point and then there was an extra couplet that I remember us filming
谁会想到呢？我不知道她高兴的是安迪，还是仅仅是疯狂填词游戏这个主意。也许两者都有。也许吧。所以我查了剧本，珍娜，我查了我的拍摄草稿，看看这个场景是不是按照我们做的那样写的。直到某一点之前都是，然后还有一段额外的对联，我记得我们拍了
because Ed was so funny and I'm so bummed it's not even in the deleted scenes on the DVD commentary and I'm going to share it with you. So in the episode, Andy reads the mad lib and it reads, the tall man entered the nice building to visit a very nice man. Sit down, Mr. Smith. Would I interest you in any good cat food? And Angela says a man eating cat food and Andy says a cat eating man food and they giggle, right?
因为埃德太搞笑了，我很遗憾它甚至没有出现在DVD评论的删减片段里，我要和你分享。所以在这一集里，安迪读了疯狂填词游戏，上面写着：高个子男人进入了漂亮的建筑去拜访一个非常好的男人。坐下，史密斯先生。我能给你介绍点好的猫粮吗？安吉拉说，一个男人吃猫粮，安迪说，一只猫吃人食，然后他们咯咯笑，对吧？
Yeah. Well, the scene would have continued. Andy starts pantomiming, being a cat, eating a hamburger and he goes, meow, a burger. Ed was so funny doing this, Jenna. And then I would have responded, a cat eating a hamburger sandwich, that's impossible. And then Andy goes, I know, and I say, where do you think of these things? And we laugh. Amazing.
是的。好吧，场景本应继续。安迪开始模仿，变成一只猫，吃汉堡包，他说，喵，汉堡。埃德做这个太搞笑了，珍娜。然后我会回应，一只猫吃汉堡三明治，那是不可能的。然后安迪说，我知道，我说，你是怎么想到这些东西的？然后我们笑了。太棒了。
A cat eating a hamburger sandwich. I'm really sad that you didn't get to hear that or see Ed pretending to be a cat eating a hamburger. Well Angela, Justin told me that Jean and Lee actually wrote this mad lib scene for Angela and Andy. So all of that was Jean and Lee. Well, it was so fun to do. I became inspired by this scene, Angela, to do a deep dive on mad libs.
一只猫吃汉堡三明治。我真的很遗憾你没能听到或看到埃德假装成一只猫吃汉堡。好吧，安吉拉，贾斯汀告诉我，吉恩和李实际上为安吉拉和安迪写了这个疯狂填词场景。所以所有这些都是吉恩和李写的。好吧，做起来太有趣了。安吉拉，我受到这个场景的启发，对疯狂填词游戏进行了深入研究。
Oh no, what'd you find? Oh my God. It is fascinating. Well, our kids love mad libs. I mean, Jenna, I did them growing up. We still do them. Same. Let me tell you the history of mad libs.
噢不，你发现了什么？噢，天哪。这太迷人了。好吧，我们的孩子喜欢疯狂填词游戏。我是说，珍娜，我从小就玩。我们现在还在玩。一样。让我告诉你疯狂填词游戏的历史。
Okay. Mad libs was invented in 1953 by two men, Leonard Stern and Roger Price. Roger Price had worked as a writer on the Bob Hope show. Leonard Stern was his friend who worked as a writer on the honeymooners. They were comedy writers. Yeah. One day, Roger went to visit Leonard at work and Leonard was working on a script for the honeymooners.
好的。疯狂填词游戏是1953年由两个人发明的，伦纳德·斯特恩和罗杰·普莱斯。罗杰·普莱斯曾在鲍勃·霍普秀担任编剧。伦纳德·斯特恩是他的朋友，曾在《蜜月期》担任编剧。他们是喜剧编剧。是的。有一天，罗杰去上班的地方拜访伦纳德，伦纳德正在为《蜜月期》写剧本。
He was trying to figure out the right word to describe the nose of Ralph Cramden's new boss. Before he could explain the whole thing, he just said to his friend, I need an adjective and Price jumped in and started throwing out words like clumsy, naked. He just started throwing out adjectives. So they thought this was so funny, right? Like, oh, a clumsy nose, a naked nose. So this gave them the idea to write a bunch of stories with missing words.
他正试图找出合适的词来描述拉尔夫·克拉姆登新老板的鼻子。在他解释清楚之前，他只是对他的朋友说，我需要一个形容词，普莱斯插话并开始抛出像笨拙、裸体这样的词。他只是开始抛出形容词。所以他们觉得这太搞笑了，对吧？比如，噢，一个笨拙的鼻子，一个裸体的鼻子。所以这给了他们写一堆缺少单词的故事的想法。
They took them to a cocktail party with their friends. They had people fill in the blanks without knowing the context and it was a huge hit. People thought this was a hoot. They tried to get these stories published, but publishers passed, nobody wanted them. They said, we don't get it. Maybe sell it to a game company or something. It sounds like a party game. So they sat on the idea for five years and then they decided to self-publish.
他们带着这些故事去参加朋友的鸡尾酒会。他们让人们在不知道上下文的情况下填空，这非常受欢迎。人们认为这太搞笑了。他们试图出版这些故事，但出版商拒绝了，没人想要它们。他们说，我们不明白。也许卖给游戏公司什么的。听起来像个派对游戏。所以他们把这个想法搁置了五年，然后决定自费出版。
But now they needed a name for it, right? They had all their stories, they're self-publishing. Get this. These two guys, they're out having breakfast in New York and they overheard an agent arguing with his client at another table. And the agent was trying to tell this actor that he had to recite a certain script for an upcoming interview. And the actor was saying, no, I want to ad-lib my interview.
但现在他们需要一个名字，对吧？他们有所有的故事，他们要自费出版。听着。这两个家伙在纽约吃早餐，无意中听到一个经纪人在另一张桌子上和他的客户争吵。经纪人试图告诉这个演员，他必须为即将到来的采访背诵某个剧本。而演员说，不，我想即兴发挥我的采访。
I want to ad-lib it. And the agent said, that would be mad to ad-lib an interview. And that's where the name Mad Lib came from. And now they have sold over 110 million copies of Mad Lib's books. That was amazing. I loved every single moment of that. I also find it really inspiring that you can have this once in a lifetime idea and, you know, don't let go of it even if it takes you six years to see it come like to fruition.
我想即兴发挥。经纪人说，即兴发挥采访太疯狂了。这就是“疯狂填词”（Mad Lib）名字的由来。现在他们已经卖出了超过1.1亿本疯狂填词书。这太棒了。我喜欢其中的每一刻。我也觉得非常鼓舞人心的是，你可以拥有这种一生一次的想法，而且，你知道，不要放弃它，即使这需要你六年时间才能看到它实现。
Yeah. They were on to something and they knew it and they made it happen. I love that. Great deep dive. Thanks. All right. Well, now Michael's going to come out of his office and immediately he's going to clock Pam and her glasses and he says to her, you know what?
是的。他们发现了什么，他们知道这一点，他们让它发生了。我喜欢那个。很棒的深度挖掘。谢谢。好了。好吧，现在迈克尔要从他的办公室出来，他会立即注意到帕姆和她的眼镜，他对她说，你知道吗？
In order to get hotter, you've got to take off those glasses. She's just going in the wrong direction. Yes. And Pam tries to explain to Michael what happened, why she's wearing these glasses, and he has this line that people quote to me all the time. He's like, it's noise coming out of an ugly scientist. Michael, I love it. That was really hard for me to get through every time Steve said that.
为了变得更性感，你必须摘掉那些眼镜。她正朝着错误的方向前进。是的。帕姆试图向迈克尔解释发生了什么，为什么她戴着这些眼镜，他有一句人们一直对我引用的台词。他说，这是从一个丑陋的科学家嘴里发出的噪音。迈克尔，我喜欢它。每次史蒂夫说那句话，我都很难坚持下去。
I bet. I feel like I've seen that on a t-shirt, Jenna. Oh, yeah. Oh, you have. Imagine for someone who's never seen the office and then like see someone in these t-shirts like Dwight, you ignorant slut. It's just noise coming out of an ugly scientist. I feel like the office has given some really random clothing choices for people.
我敢打赌。我觉得我在T恤上见过那个，珍娜。噢，是的。噢，你见过。想象一下对于一个从未看过《办公室》的人，然后看到有人穿着这些T恤，比如“德怀特，你这个无知的荡妇”。这只是从一个丑陋的科学家嘴里发出的噪音。我觉得《办公室》给人们提供了一些非常随机的服装选择。
Well, when I got my glasses in real life and I posted my first picture on Instagram of myself in my new glasses, people started putting all of these comments. They were like, you're going in the wrong direction. You have to take off your glasses to get hotter. And then other people were like, it's noise coming out of, I was so offended. I forgot about this scene in the office. And I was like, why is everybody coming down on me? I thought my glasses were cute.
好吧，当我在现实生活中戴上眼镜，并在Instagram上发布了我戴着新眼镜的第一张照片时，人们开始发表所有这些评论。他们说，你正朝着错误的方向前进。你必须摘掉眼镜才能变得更性感。然后其他人说，这是从……发出的噪音，我太被冒犯了。我忘记了《办公室》里的这个场景。我当时想，为什么每个人都在针对我？我觉得我的眼镜很可爱。
I know. I so relate. One time I posted a photo early in my Instagram days in a green sweater and someone was like, looking a little hoarse, aren't we? And I was like, wow, how rude. And then I was like, oh, right, green is hoarse. Okay, okay, got it, got it, got it. I know.
我知道。我太有共鸣了。有一次我在Instagram早期发布了一张穿着绿色毛衣的照片，有人说，看起来有点嘶哑，不是吗？我当时想，哇，多粗鲁。然后我当时想，噢，对了，绿色是嘶哑。好吧，好吧，知道了，知道了，知道了。我知道。
Sometimes I forget. I'm actually grateful that we're doing this rewatch because I feel like I'm less likely to be offended by comments now because they're actually quotes. Well, after all the insults, Michael tells everyone to go into the conference room for a brainstorming session. Oh, lady, there is a scene between Jim and Pam that is not in this episode. And it's not in the deleted scene. So you have to tell me if you guys film this, it's kind of racy.
有时我忘了。我实际上很感激我们正在重温，因为我觉得我现在不太可能被评论冒犯，因为它们实际上是引语。好吧，在所有的侮辱之后，迈克尔告诉大家去会议室进行头脑风暴会议。噢，女士，吉姆和帕姆之间有一个场景不在这一集里。而且它不在删减片段里。所以你必须告诉我你们是否拍了这个，它有点色情。
You want to hear it? What? So I'm reading the shooting draft last night and this is in there. As people head to the conference room, Jim smiles at Pam. Jim says, the price you pay for a night in heaven. Oh, wait. Pam glances at the camera, stilted. Yes, the movies were good, Jim.
你想听吗？什么？所以我昨晚在读拍摄草稿，里面有这个。当人们前往会议室时，吉姆对帕姆微笑。吉姆说，在天堂过夜的代价。噢，等等。帕姆瞥了一眼摄像机，僵住了。是的，电影很好，吉姆。
Jim says, you mean the movies that we made of us making love? Pam, panicking, glances to camera, shut up. We didn't film ourselves. Jim to camera, hi, Pam's grandma, sorry you had to find out like this. And then Pam hits Jim and they go into the conference room. I don't remember if we filmed that. If it's in the shooting draft, we must have. People would have lost their minds if we'd left that in the show.
吉姆说，你是说我们拍的我们做爱的电影？帕姆，惊慌失措，瞥了一眼摄像机，闭嘴。我们没拍我们自己。吉姆对摄像机，嗨，帕姆的奶奶，抱歉你不得不这样发现。然后帕姆打了吉姆，他们进了会议室。我不记得我们是否拍了那个。如果它在拍摄草稿里，我们一定拍了。如果我们在节目中保留那个，人们会疯掉的。
I know. Like what the heck? I read it last night and I was like, like I did a spit take. I was like, what's happening with Jim and Pam? Just hearing that makes me feel like I've just walked in on my parents. I know. Having an intimate moment. Like, I just like, no, no, no, don't want to see it.
我知道。就像什么鬼？我昨晚读了它，我当时想，就像我喷了一口水。我当时想，吉姆和帕姆发生了什么？仅仅听到那个就让我觉得我刚刚撞见了我父母。我知道。有亲密的时刻。就像，我只是，不，不，不，不想看到它。
Don't want to see it. Which is probably why it was edited out. But it cracked me up reading it. Wow. Well, there you go, guys. There you go. Now we're in the conference room and the actual scene they leave in between the two of you guys is Jim proposing to Pam, which is also in the script.
不想看到它。这可能就是为什么它被剪掉了。但读到它让我笑得前仰后合。哇。好吧，伙计们，就是这样。就是这样。现在我们在会议室里，他们保留在你们两个之间的实际场景是吉姆向帕姆求婚，这也在剧本里。
So I guess if they had to choose one, that one is a little bit more in character for you guys. Well, proposing that I go get him some more coffee. Right, right, right. But you're doing the thing. You know, he's now doing this bit with you, right? Yeah. Well, Michael has written the words energize in block letters on a piece of paper up front.
所以我猜如果他们必须选一个，那一个对你们来说更符合角色。好吧，提议我去给他拿更多咖啡。对，对，对。但你在做那件事。你知道，他现在在和你玩这个梗，对吧？是的。好吧，迈克尔在前面的纸上用大写字母写了“激励”这个词。
And he wants to know how can we energize the office? A few people are throwing out ideas. Andy suggests that we have a new outgoing message, something with a zing and pep. Some suggest we have an even better message with more zing and more pep. Michael wants to get Stanley's opinion. Stanley's not having it. He's like, not me. He's not interested.
他想知道我们如何激励办公室？几个人提出了一些想法。安迪建议我们有一个新的外呼信息，带点活力和干劲。有些人建议我们有一个更好的信息，有更多的活力和更多的干劲。迈克尔想听听斯坦利的意见。斯坦利不买账。他就像，不是我。他不感兴趣。
He's not even answering him. I know. And Michael keeps pushing and pushing and pushing. And that is when he says the line, did I stutter? And everyone is stunned. We're like, whoa, this just took a turn. Michael excuses himself for a glass of water. Oof.
他甚至没回答他。我知道。迈克尔不断地推，推，推。那就是他说那句台词的时候，“我结巴了吗？”每个人都惊呆了。我们就像，哇，这发生了一个转折。迈克尔借口去喝杯水。噢。
Oof. Now, Jenna, per Justin Spitzer, this is the only episode title that was an actual line in the script. Yes. Justin said he had originally thought they should call it in subordination. Oh. But they settled on did I stutter? Well, I like did I stutter better?
噢。现在，珍娜，根据贾斯汀·斯皮策的说法，这是唯一一个实际上是剧本台词的剧集标题。是的。贾斯汀说他最初认为他们应该叫它“抗命”。噢。但他们决定叫“我结巴了吗？”好吧，我更喜欢“我结巴了吗？”
Me too. First up, we're in Michael's office and Toby is sitting with him and he's trying to tell Michael that he needs to talk with Stanley about his in subordination. And once again, Toby is in Michael's corner and Michael just refuses to see Toby as someone who could be there for him. Yeah. He tries to tell Toby that he misinterpreted what he saw, that they were actually a couple of pals are kind of joshing around.
我也是。首先，我们在迈克尔的办公室，托比和他坐在一起，他试图告诉迈克尔他需要和斯坦利谈谈他的抗命。再一次，托比站在迈克尔这边，而迈克尔只是拒绝把托比看作是一个可以为他着想的人。是的。他试图告诉托比他误解了他所看到的，他们实际上是一对伙伴在开玩笑。
Toby wouldn't know because Toby doesn't have friends, Michael says. Yeah. If you had a friend, you would say something like this, hey, you're poor, well, hey, your mom is dead. That's what friends do. Yeah. So there you go, Toby, get some friends. But it's clear at the end of this meeting that Michael is going to be expected to do
托比不会知道，因为托比没有朋友，迈克尔说。是的。如果你有一个朋友，你会说这样的话，嘿，你很穷，好吧，嘿，你妈妈死了。这就是朋友做的事。是的。所以就这样，托比，交些朋友吧。但这次会议结束时很清楚，迈克尔将被期望做
something about what happened. It's also clear that Michael's really anxious about it. He says he has a stomach ache. And Jenna, there's a deleted scene. It's so great. First of all, it shows the geography of Dunder Mifflin in a whole new way that we've never seen before. So in this deleted scene, there's a talking head and it's over the action.
点什么来应对发生的事情。也很清楚迈克尔对此非常焦虑。他说他胃痛。而且珍娜，有一个删减片段。太棒了。首先，它以一种我们从未见过的方式展示了邓德·米夫林的地理位置。所以在那个删减片段里，有一个采访，它在动作之上。
You know what I mean? And Michael is talking about how him and Stanley are friends. In fact, Stanley is one of his oldest friends. But while he's saying all this, he's walking out of his office and he clearly has to go pee and he sees Stanley and he pivots hard right. He goes out the front door of Dunder Mifflin, pass the elevators to the stairwell door next to Vance for refrigeration. He goes down the stairs out the front door of Dunder Mifflin, through the parking lot,
你知道我的意思吗？迈克尔正在谈论他和斯坦利是朋友。事实上，斯坦利是他最老的朋友之一。但在他说这一切的时候，他正走出他的办公室，他显然必须去撒尿，他看到了斯坦利，他猛地向右转。他从邓德·米夫林的前门走出去，经过电梯到万斯制冷旁边的楼梯间门。他走下楼梯，走出邓德·米夫林的前门，穿过停车场，
to a back door that's another stairwell, up those stairs, and he comes out by the break room, by the vending machines. And then he walks through the annex, into the kitchen, into the men's room. That's what he did, because he had to go pee and he did not want to walk past Stanley's desk. Wow. And we've never seen anyone in the run of the show come up the back stairwell into the area where the break room is.
到另一个楼梯间的后门，上那些楼梯，他从休息室旁边，自动售货机旁边出来。然后他穿过附楼，进入厨房，进入男厕所。这就是他做的，因为他必须去撒尿，他不想走过斯坦利的办公桌。哇。而且我们从未在节目中看到任何人从后楼梯间上来进入休息室所在的区域。
That's right. I loved it just visually and that shows you the extremes he was going to to avoid Stanley. Well now we're going to get into the B storyline of this episode, which is that Andy is selling his car, his Xterra, and Dwight is going to buy it. His Xterra when he was driving a Prius, so I don't know what's happening here. I know. What's that about? You know what, in my mind it was like his old car from college.
没错。我喜欢它，仅仅从视觉上，这向你展示了他为了避开斯坦利所采取的极端措施。好吧，现在我们要进入这一集的B故事线，也就是安迪在卖他的车，他的Xterra，而德怀特要买它。他的Xterra，当他开着普锐斯时，所以我不知道这里发生了什么。我知道。那是怎么回事？你知道吗，在我脑海里，那就像他大学时的旧车。
Maybe so. From his Cornell days? Well, we had a fan question from Barbara G. and Rebecca H. At 6 minutes 45 seconds, Dwight points out that there's a scratch on Andy's Xterra. In a deleted scene from safety training, Angela, you might remember, Angela keys Andy's car. Did Angela also key his Xterra? I don't think so. I think she just keyed the Prius, but in the script, you guys, Angela is watching all of
也许吧。从他康奈尔大学的日子开始？好吧，我们收到了来自芭芭拉·G和丽贝卡·H的粉丝提问。在6分45秒，德怀特指出安迪的Xterra上有划痕。在《安全培训》的一个删减片段里，安吉拉，你可能记得，安吉拉划了安迪的车。安吉拉也划了他的Xterra吗？我不这么认为。我想她只是划了普锐斯，但在剧本里，伙计们，安吉拉正在看着所有
this interaction between Dwight and Andy. She is perhaps titillated by it, fascinated, curious, but there are several scenes where she's peering through the window, the camera buster at one point and she gets agitated. So she is sort of watching all of this all day long. Well Dwight ends up bullying Andy into selling him the car at a very low rate, way under asking. He does that thing where he's like, do it, sell it, give it to me, say yes now, say yes now.
这些德怀特和安迪之间的互动。她可能被它挑逗了，着迷，好奇，但有几个场景她透过窗户窥视，摄像机在某一点拍到了她，她变得焦躁不安。所以她整天都在看着这一切。好吧，德怀特最终欺负安迪以非常低的价格卖给他车，远低于要价。他做了那种他就像，做吧，卖吧，给我，现在说是，现在说是。
Three, two, one, five, four, three, say yes. And it works. He says, okay, now here's an interesting tidbit. This car, this Xterra actually belonged to our hairdresser, Kim Fairy. And she was actually selling it. She was. It was so crazy. She let us borrow her car for this episode and then she sold it, just like these guys.
三，二，一，五，四，三，说是。而且它奏效了。他说，好吧，现在这是一个有趣的细节。这辆车，这辆Xterra实际上属于我们的发型师，金·费里。而且她实际上在卖它。她确实在卖。这太疯狂了。她让我们借用她的车拍这一集，然后她把它卖了，就像这些家伙一样。
Well, I guess Michael is going to finally baby step up to Stanley's desk and he's basically going to forgive Stanley before Stanley has even apologized. But the way he approaches Stanley really reminds me of like when my kids want something, but they don't want to ask me and they just come and stand by you and kind of hover. Yeah. He just standing next to Stanley's desk and Stanley's like, yeah, what do you want? Yeah. And he's like, you know, nothing.
好吧，我想迈克尔终于要迈出婴儿步走到斯坦利的办公桌前，他基本上要在斯坦利道歉之前原谅斯坦利。但他接近斯坦利的方式真的让我想起当我的孩子想要什么时，但他们不想问我，他们只是过来站在你身边，有点徘徊。是的。他只是站在斯坦利的办公桌旁边，斯坦利就像，是，你想要什么？是的。他说，你知道，没什么。
I think I just want to say like, we're cool, right? Like, I forgive you and we've forgotten about what happened, right? Yeah. Now, Stanley could just say yes. I know. But he does not. I think Stanley has had years of putting up with Michael and he's just had it. Yeah.
我想我只是想说，我们很酷，对吧？就像，我原谅你了，我们已经忘记了发生的事情，对吧？是的。现在，斯坦利可以只说是的。我知道。但他没有。我想斯坦利已经忍受了迈克尔多年，他受够了。是的。
Since that didn't work, Michael is going to sit with Dwight and try to figure out, is there a way that someone else might be able to discipline Stanley? Is Stanley report to anyone else besides Michael? And this is when Dwight gets out his very extensive, very hilarious employee org chart. It's so elaborate. It was really well made. He has a like tripod he sets it on. There's like an overlay.
既然那没用，迈克尔要和德怀特坐在一起，试图弄清楚，有没有可能其他人能管教斯坦利？斯坦利除了迈克尔还向谁汇报？这就是德怀特拿出他非常详尽、非常搞笑的员工组织结构图的时候。它太复杂了。它做得非常好。他有一个三脚架，他把它放在上面。有一个覆盖层。
I mean, Jenna, this thing was not cheap. Well, Brent told us that the entire writing staff put a huge amount of time and effort into that org chart. And that they had the idea that after this episode, NBC could sell the org chart as posters. So they filled it with all these little jokes that you can't even really spot in the episode itself. And unfortunately though, the poster did not become the runaway bestseller. They hoped it would be, however, Kent Sabornak sent me a picture of it and we will put it
我是说，珍娜，这东西不便宜。好吧，布伦特告诉我们，整个编剧团队在那个组织结构图上投入了大量的时间和精力。而且他们有一个想法，在这一集之后，NBC可以把组织结构图作为海报出售。所以他们填满了所有这些小笑话，你甚至无法在剧集本身中真正发现。但不幸的是，海报并没有成为他们希望的那样畅销书，然而，肯特·萨博纳克给我发了一张照片，我们会把它
in the pod so you can really unpack it if you'd like. Yeah, I looked at that last night and the detail of the menstruation cycles of the women, you know, Dwight has shared that he clocks all of that. Well, he wasn't kidding. Angela, we got a fan question about this scene at nine minutes, 34 seconds. Did Rain improvised touching Michael's face with his pointer? Yes. Yes, he did.
放在播客里，如果你愿意的话，你可以真正解开它。是的，我昨晚看了那个，关于女性月经周期的细节，你知道，德怀特分享说他记录了所有这些。好吧，他没开玩笑。安吉拉，我们收到了关于这个场景的粉丝提问，在9分34秒。雷恩即兴发挥用他的指针触碰迈克尔的脸了吗？是的。是的，他做了。
And they could not get through it. They were cracking up something so sort of delicate and intimate about Dwight touching Michael's face with that metal pointer and those two fellas were just disintegrating into laughter. It's in the bloopers. It's so fun to watch. Justin said before they started the scene, they had to decide whether or not Rain would have that metal pointer or a laser pointer.
他们无法坚持下去。他们快要笑疯了，德怀特用金属教鞭触碰迈克尔脸部的动作既微妙又亲密，那两个家伙简直笑得前仰后合。这在花絮里，看起来太有趣了。贾斯汀说在开始拍摄那场戏之前，他们必须决定雷恩是用金属教鞭还是激光笔。
And he's so glad. I'm so glad they gave him the metal pointer. Yeah, Brent said that after Rain improvised it once, they loved it and they had him do it again and it took over seven takes before they got even three seconds of usable footage. And that's what you see in the episode was like take number eight. Well back at reception, Kevin is complimenting Pam's glasses. I mean, they're kind of a turn on for him. Jenna, there's a lot more in the script.
他很高兴，我也很高兴他们给了他金属教鞭。是的，布伦特说在雷恩即兴发挥了一次之后，他们非常喜欢，就让他再做了一次，拍了七次以上才得到三秒钟可用的镜头。你在剧集中看到的就是第八次拍摄的成果。回到前台，凯文在夸奖帕姆的眼镜。我是说，这对他来说有点吸引力。珍娜，剧本里还有很多内容。
In fact, Kevin says you're basically in his league now. So I think there were a few alts for this scene. I remember shooting it. We were laughing so hard. There's also that famous line where he says, can you say these are due back Thursday? And Pam's like, no, no, at nine minutes, 58 seconds at the very top of this interaction between Pam and Kevin, I want you to know that John is actively playing free cell on his computer.
事实上，凯文说你现在基本和他是一个档次的了。所以我认为这场戏有几个备选方案。我记得拍摄的时候，我们笑得太厉害了。还有那句名言，他说：“你能说这些周四到期吗？”帕姆说：“不，不。”在帕姆和凯文这段互动的最开始，九分五十八秒的时候，我想让你知道约翰正在电脑上玩纸牌游戏。
Oh, I saw it. It's not just on his computer. You can see him moving the car. Oh, no, he's full on playing. But this interaction between Kevin and Pam is going to cause Pam to take her glasses off now for the rest of the day. She's done. She's sick of the comments.
哦，我看到了。不仅仅是在他的电脑上，你可以看到他在移动纸牌。哦，不，他完全是在玩。但凯文和帕姆之间的这次互动导致帕姆在接下来的一天里摘掉了眼镜。她受够了，她厌倦了这些评论。
She's just going to not see. But how bad is this woman's vision? Because she takes her glasses off and then Jenna, the phone rings and she has a hard time finding the handle of the phone. There is a talking head that did not make it in the episode where Pam says that her vision is 20 slash 400. I'll have you know, Angela, legal blindness is anything that's 20 slash 200 or worse. So Pam would be considered legally blind without her glasses or contacts.
她打算就这样看不清。但这女人的视力到底有多差？因为她摘下眼镜后，珍娜，电话响了，她很难找到电话听筒。有一个没被剪进剧集的采访片段，帕姆说她的视力是20/400。安吉拉，我要告诉你，法律意义上的盲人是指视力在20/200或更差。所以帕姆如果不戴眼镜或隐形眼镜，会被视为法律意义上的盲人。
And basically what it means is that Pam can see things 20 feet away, but normal people could see that same thing 400 feet away. So it doesn't really track that Pam can't see the phone. Okay. What it should mean is that she can't see Stanley anymore. Okay. Yeah. So maybe we didn't research her eyesight properly, but in general, though, all of her vision
基本上这意味着帕姆能看到20英尺外的东西，而正常人能看到400英尺外的东西。所以帕姆看不见电话的说法不太成立。好吧，它应该意味着她再也看不见斯坦利了。好吧。所以也许我们没有正确研究她的视力，但总的来说，她的视力
would be fairly blurry. I do remember researching that. Well, I thought you played it so well, Jenna, because that's not an easy thing to play. And the physicality of your comedy in this episode is fantastic. Well, thank you very much. Yeah. Well, guys, Michael's going to go down to the warehouse and try to get maybe some advice on how to deal with Stanley.
会相当模糊。我确实记得研究过那个。好吧，我觉得你演得很好，珍娜，因为那不是一件容易演好的事。而且你在这集里的肢体喜剧表现非常棒。好吧，非常感谢。是的。好了，伙计们，迈克尔要下到仓库去，试着寻求一些关于如何处理斯坦利的建议。
But before we go there, let's take a break and then we'll come back to learn a little bit about fluffy fingers. Okay, guys, we're back and as promised, we're going to break down this scene. Between Michael and Daryl, it's amazing. Everything about it is amazing. Even just from a technical standpoint, this was such a tiny, tiny room and Randall had to shoot through the door in a window and capture this moment. It's so beautifully done.
但在我们去那里之前，让我们休息一下，回来后再了解一点关于“毛茸茸的手指”的事。好了，伙计们，我们回来了，正如承诺的那样，我们要剖析迈克尔和达里尔之间的这场戏，太棒了。关于它的一切都很棒。即使从技术角度来看，这是一个非常非常小的房间，兰德尔必须透过门上的窗户拍摄并捕捉这一刻。做得太漂亮了。
Michael's going to ask Daryl, hey, man, have you ever been in a gang? And Daryl needs to know what Michael needs to say. Yeah. He says he has been in not just one gang, but several. Yeah. He has been in the Crips and the Bloods and the Warriors and the Newsies and the Newsies on Broadway. And Michael is just like, oh my God, yeah, oh my God.
迈克尔要问达里尔：“嘿，伙计，你参加过帮派吗？”达里尔需要知道迈克尔想说什么。是的，他说他参加过，不仅是一个，而是好几个。是的，他参加过瘸帮、血帮、勇士帮、报童帮，还有百老汇的报童帮。迈克尔简直是：“哦，天哪，是的，哦，天哪。”
And Michael can't believe that Daryl is now about to share with him his like deep gang knowledge. Yeah. What do you do if you're disrespected in the gang? Daryl's going to tell him they do something called fluffy fingers and that is where you surprise the person by tickling them. And you keep tickling them until they start to tickle you and then you're just tickling each other.
迈克尔简直不敢相信达里尔现在要和他分享他那深厚的帮派知识。是的，如果你在帮派里受到不尊重该怎么办？达里尔要告诉他他们做一种叫“毛茸茸的手指”的事，那就是你通过挠对方痒痒来给对方惊喜。你一直挠他们，直到他们开始挠你，然后你们就在互相挠痒痒。
Yeah. And then you're over it. It's really effective, he says. And Michael's like, wow, I didn't think that went in the gangs, but okay, okay. Michael's like, all right, I guess I should try this. It's so great. And both Steve and Craig play it perfectly. Oh, yeah.
是的，然后你就释怀了。他说这非常有效。迈克尔说：“哇，我没想到帮派里还有这个，但好吧，好吧。”迈克尔说：“好吧，我想我应该试试这个。”太棒了。史蒂夫和克雷格都演得非常完美。哦，是的。
Well, you know, Jenna, there was a deleted scene where Michael tries to get up the courage to tickle Stanley, to do the fluffy fingers. It's insane. Stanley is at the supply cabinet. He's kind of reaching up to grab something and Michael sneaks up behind him and he holds his hands up like he's going to tickle him, but then he just can't quite figure out how to do it. And Stanley doesn't even notice and Michael backs away.
嗯，你知道，珍娜，有一个被删减的场景，迈克尔试图鼓起勇气去挠斯坦利，去做“毛茸茸的手指”。太疯狂了。斯坦利在储物柜旁，他正伸手去拿东西，迈克尔悄悄走到他身后，举起手好像要挠他，但他就是不知道该怎么做。斯坦利甚至没注意到，迈克尔就退缩了。
And then Michael has a deleted talking head where he says, it's not Daryl's fault. It was a great idea. I just couldn't quite figure out how to do it. I don't know. I've tried everything. I'm running out of options. Yeah. And when you run out of options, you decide to fake fire someone.
然后迈克尔有一个被删减的采访片段，他说：“这不是达里尔的错。这是个好主意。我只是没弄明白该怎么做。我不知道。我试过一切了。我快没招了。”是的，当你没招的时候，你就会决定假装解雇某人。
That's what Michael does. Oh, Michael. So now Ryan has arrived. He pulls up in his convertible. His shirt is open. He winks at himself in the rearview mirror. Oh, yeah. He's feeling real good.
这就是迈克尔做的。哦，迈克尔。现在瑞安到了。他开着敞篷车停下。他的衬衫敞开着。他在后视镜里对自己眨眼。哦，是的。他感觉好极了。
And there was a deleted scene, Jenna, that was so good. He comes in the office. He's got bagels, but Pam doesn't have her glasses on. He tosses a bagel at her. She can't see it. It hits her in the face. And then he goes on, Jenna, to show Pam how to eat a bagel. He just, with his own hands, starts digging out all the good part of the bagel, all the
而且有一个被删减的场景，珍娜，太棒了。他走进办公室。他带着百吉饼，但帕姆没戴眼镜。他把一个百吉饼扔向她。她看不见。它打在她的脸上。然后他继续，珍娜，教帕姆怎么吃百吉饼。他只是用自己的手，开始挖出百吉饼里所有好的部分，所有
middle part. And he says, yeah, you just eat that outer part, you know, so you don't gain weight. And he kind of points to Pam's belly. Yeah. And I felt like that whole scene showed his state of mind, how manic he is throwing the bagels, digging them apart, like, oh my gosh. I remember shooting that. I was sad it didn't make it in because that was really fun.
中间的部分。他说：“是的，你只吃外面的部分，你知道，这样你就不会发胖。”他指了指帕姆的肚子。是的，我觉得整个场景展示了他的精神状态，他有多狂躁，扔百吉饼，把它们挖开，就像，哦，天哪。我记得拍摄那个场景。我很遗憾它没被剪进去，因为那真的很有趣。
You were so good in it. I mean, he's like, he tosses a bagel at you and Jenna, I really believed you didn't see it. That's how good you are in the scene. Anyway, so Ryan is here. He's actually got some big business. He goes in the conference room and he calls Jim in. Toby's there and he's going to give him a formal warning about his job performance.
你在里面演得太好了。我是说，他向你扔百吉饼，珍娜，我真的相信你没看见。这就是你在戏里演得有多好。总之，瑞安来了。他确实有一些大生意。他走进会议室，叫吉姆进去。托比也在那里，他要给吉姆一个关于他工作表现的正式警告。
But the way he calls him in is so amazing. He's like, hey, Jim, Jim, I got to ask you a question as a true Eagles fan. Oh, so slimy. I thought BJ was so good in this scene. He was like every douchebag I've ever had a meeting with. I actually recorded it off my computer and I texted it to him and I said, BJ, we're watching Did I Stutter and you are so brilliant and amazing in the scene. I just needed you to watch it so you can see how good you are.
但他叫他进去的方式太棒了。他说：“嘿，吉姆，吉姆，我得作为一个真正的老鹰队球迷问你一个问题。”哦，太油腻了。我觉得BJ在这场戏里演得太好了。他就像我遇到过的每一个混蛋。我实际上用电脑录了下来，发短信给他，我说：“BJ，我们正在看《我结巴了吗》，你在这场戏里太出色、太棒了。我只是需要你看看，这样你就能看到你演得有多好。”
And he wrote me back and he was like, Jenna, oh my God, I forgot about that scene. Thank you for sending this to me. That was so fun to watch. But that happens when we are rewatching this show. Sometimes I will see one of our friends perform just like madness level amazing and I just send it to him. I'm like, you need to be reminded of what an amazing comedic actor you are. You're welcome.
他回信说：“珍娜，哦，天哪，我忘了那个场景了。谢谢你发给我。看那个太有趣了。”但当我们重温这部剧时，这种情况就会发生。有时我会看到我们的朋友表演得简直是疯狂地好，我就发给他。我说：“你需要被提醒你是一位多么出色的喜剧演员。不客气。”
Oh, for sure. I had a whole text thread with Phyllis because I was like Phyllis, you are so amazing. Back in Yankee Swap, she's so good. I know. Yes, BJ is so good in these moments and Jim is like, is this because I talked to David Wallace and Ryan's like, no, no, no, I appreciate, you know, constructive criticism. I thrive on it. Yeah.
哦，当然。我和菲利斯有一个完整的短信串，因为我说：“菲利斯，你太棒了。回到《洋基交换》，她演得太好了。”我知道。是的，BJ在这些时刻演得太好了，吉姆说：“这是因为我和大卫·华莱士谈过吗？”瑞安说：“不，不，不，我很欣赏，你知道，建设性的批评。我靠它茁壮成长。”是的。
So do she. And he says you can get more details from Toby. This leads to a Toby talking head. And dare I say that Toby seems smug? Oh, for sure. Yeah. Toby says I'd say all the goofing around at Pam's desk and hanging out with Pam is finally caught up with him.
她也是。他说你可以从托比那里得到更多细节。这引出了一个托比的采访片段。我敢说托比看起来很自鸣得意吗？哦，当然。是的。托比说：“我想说，在帕姆桌子旁的所有胡闹和与帕姆混在一起终于让他自食其果了。”
Fans were furious, Jenna. When this episode came out, they hated Toby so much. I mean, in the episode before he put his hand on Pam's knee. And now it seems like he's going behind Jim's back to try to get him fired. Oh, yeah. And Jenna, if you thought you hated Toby with that talking head, had you seen the deleted scene between Jim and Toby? And then Ryan, you would have been like, oh my God, people would have, Toby would not
粉丝们很愤怒，珍娜。当这一集播出时，他们非常讨厌托比。我是说，在上一集里，他把手放在帕姆的膝盖上。现在看起来他要背着吉姆试图让他被解雇。哦，是的。而且珍娜，如果你以为你讨厌那个采访片段里的托比，如果你看过吉姆和托比之间的那个被删减的场景，然后是瑞安，你会说：“哦，天哪，人们会，托比将无法从中恢复过来。”萨姆，你能播放那个被删减的场景吗？“正式警告，认真的吗？”“嗯，如你所知，这些年来他针对你提交了很多投诉。”“我知道，我也关心。但现在它被视为一个生产力问题。”“生产力。我的数字很好。”
have been able to come back from it. Sam, can you play that deleted scene? A formal warning, seriously. Well, as you know, the way he's filed a lot of complaints against you over the years. I know and care. But now it's being looked at as more of a productivity issue. Productivity. My numbers are good.
“我知道。但瑞安认为它们还不够好。”“保卢斯喜欢吉姆。所以针对他，对我来说是一个冒险的举动。但在商业中，你必须冒险。有时你必须开着敞篷车走在开阔的公路上。”哦，天哪。瑞安正试图把他的车顶放下来，但它放不下来。
I know. But Ryan thinks that they're not good enough. Paulus likes Jim. So going after him, that's a risky move for me. But in business, you've got to take risks. Sometimes you've got to get out on the open highway with a top down. Oh my God. And Ryan is trying to put the top down to his car and it won't go down.
哇。但是，是的，你能想象如果那些场景被保留下来会怎样吗？哦。好吧，安吉拉，说到背叛，德怀特洗了那辆Xterra，现在正以超过9000美元的价格转售。他在盈利出售。哦，安迪说：“搞什么鬼，伙计？”安吉拉印象深刻。
Wow. But yeah, can you imagine if those scenes had been left in? Oh. Well, Angela, speaking of treachery, Dwight has washed the exterra and he's now reselling it for over $9,000. He's selling it for a profit. Oh, and Andy is like, what the hell, man? Angela's impressed.
安吉拉说：“哦，是的。你抓住了他。你更聪明。”她喜欢两个男人为她决斗。她真的喜欢。我知道。你们记得，迈克尔已经没招了。安迪的手指对他不起作用。
Angela's like, oh yeah. You got him. You're smarter. She loves two men dueling over her. She really does. I know. You guys remember, Michael has run out of options. Andy Fingers isn't going to work for him.
所以他必须做他不想做的事。他必须假装解雇斯坦利来给他一个教训。他从办公室出来，向大家宣布。他说：“伙计们，伙计们，伙计们，听着，我要假装解雇斯坦利，但我只是想让你们表现得好像我真的在解雇斯坦利一样。”每个人都说：“如果你没告诉我们你在做什么，我们会反应正确的。”他说：“哦，天哪，你们为什么不理解这个？”
So he's going to have to do the thing he didn't want to do. He's going to have to fake fire Stanley to teach him a lesson. And he comes out of his office and he announces it to everyone. He says, guys, guys, guys, listen, I'm going to fake fire Stanley, but I just want you to react as if I'm really firing Stanley. And everybody's like, if you hadn't told us what you were doing, we would have reacted correctly. And he's like, oh my gosh, why aren't you understanding this?
说这话的人，作为理智之声的人是凯文。我知道。当凯文成为理智之声时，你就知道你有麻烦了。斯坦利走进办公区，迈克尔假装解雇他，结果并不好。斯坦利对他发泄了一通侮辱。我记得我们拍摄的时候，珍娜，你可以听到针掉在地上的声音。是的。那是一个非常美丽的戏剧性时刻。
The person that says it, the person that's the voice of reason is Kevin. I know. You know you're in trouble when Kevin is the voice of reason. Stanley walks into the bullpen and Michael fake fires him and it does not go well. Stanley unleashes on him just a tirade of insults. I remember when we filmed this, Jenna, and you could have heard a pin drop. Yes. It was such a beautifully dramatic moment.
莱斯利演得太棒了。是的，伙计们，我们联系了莱斯利，因为我们真的、真的很想让他今天来播客，因为这对他来说是一个非常精彩的故事情节和表演。他这周在拍摄。他在拍东西，不能来，但他确实想让我们和你分享，这段独白是完全写好的。这不是即兴创作，你知道，我记得安吉拉，他为此努力过，他表演得就像一场精彩的演出，他每次拍摄都演得很好。
Leslie crushed it. Yeah, you guys, we reached out to Leslie because we really, really wanted him to come on the pod today because this is just a tour de force storyline and performance by him in this episode. And he is filming this week. He is filming something and he couldn't come on, but he did want us to share with you that this monologue was completely scripted. This was not improvised, you know, and I remember Angela that he worked on this and he delivered it like it was just an amazing performance and he nailed it every take.
每次拍摄。他百分之百背下了台词。他准备好全力以赴，我们都为他感到高兴。这一刻太棒了，我记得我们在场景结束时都鼓掌了。是的。好吧，迈克尔把所有人都赶走了。他大喊说：“所有人出去，除了斯坦利。所有人出去。”
Every take. He was 100% off book. He showed up ready to throw it down and we were just all so happy for him. This moment was amazing and I remember us all applauding at the end of the scene. Yeah. Well, Michael throws everybody out. He yells and says, everybody get out, everybody except Stanley. Everybody out.
每个人都滚蛋了，珍娜，在剧本里，虽然不在被删减的场景里，但在剧本里，迈克尔转向摄像机说：“你们两个摄像机也出去。所有人。”哇。这就是为什么在18分17秒，你看到摄像机偷偷溜回来。因为在剧本里，迈克尔告诉他们出去。我喜欢那个举动。我喜欢它，因为当迈克尔和斯坦利单独在一起，或者认为他单独和斯坦利在一起时，
And everyone gets the hell out and Jenna in the script, which isn't in the deleted scenes, but in the script, Michael turns to the cameras and says, you two cameras out of here. Everybody. Wow. And that's why at 18 minutes, 17 seconds, you see the cameras sneak back in. It's because in the script, Michael told them to get out. I loved that move. I loved it because when Michael is alone with Stanley or thinks he's alone with Stanley,
他变得非常脆弱。他眼里含着泪水，说：“你为什么找我麻烦？就像，你为什么要这样找我麻烦？”这真的很脆弱。斯坦利非常实事求是地说：“我不尊重你。”然后我觉得迈克尔有了一个诚实的时刻，如果摄像机在那里就不可能发生，他说：“好吧，我接受。你不尊重我。”
he gets really vulnerable. There's tears in his eyes and he says, why do you pick on me? Like, why do you pick on me like this? And it's really vulnerable. And Stanley very matter of fact, he says, I don't respect you. And then I felt like Michael had such an honest moment that could not have happened if the cameras were there where he says, fine, I accept that. You don't respect me.
“我接受，但你不能在这里那样跟我说话。我是你的老板，这绝对不行。”我同意你的看法，安吉拉。每当迈克尔知道摄像机在那里时，他总是忍不住要为它们表演。所以我感觉我们看到了迈克尔·斯科特的一面，只有在他不知道摄像机在那里时才能看到。是的。
I accept it, but you can't talk to me like that here. I am your boss and it just cannot be done. And I agree with you, Angela. Any time Michael knows the cameras are there, he can't help but perform in some way for them. And so I feel like we're seeing a side of Michael Scott that can only be seen when he doesn't know the cameras are there. Yeah.
那是我们节目中非常有趣的一部分，玩弄当我们的角色知道摄像机在那里和不知道时他们是谁。我喜欢我们能以这些不同的方式揭示我们自己这些不同的小部分。哦，我也是。这让节目变得如此丰富，对吧？太酷了。你知道吗？
And that was such a fun part of our show, playing with who are our characters when we know the cameras are there and when we don't. And I loved that we got to reveal these little different parts of ourselves in these different ways. Oh, me too. It made the show so rich, right? It's cool. And you know what?
他们有了这个解决的时刻。他们就像：“好吧。我们现在知道我们的交战规则了，对吧？”是的，他们握手。完成了。这导致迈克尔有了一个采访片段。他真的被尊重的想法困住了，得不到尊重。这让他的大脑进入了罗德尼·丹杰菲尔德的世界。
They have this moment of resolution. They're like, fine. We now know our rules of engagement, right? Yeah, they shake hands. Done. And this leads to Michael having a talking head. He's really stuck on the idea of respect, getting no respect. And this just sends his brain into Rodney Dangerfield land.
所以他要做一些真正即兴的罗德尼·丹杰菲尔德模仿，然后演变成杰夫·福克斯沃西的模仿，然后是波拉特，然后是杰瑞·宋飞，然后又回到罗德尼·丹杰菲尔德。这是一个相当史诗般的采访片段。确实。而且你知道，珍娜，那个采访片段，整个罗德尼·丹杰菲尔德的喜剧即兴表演不在拍摄草稿中。那是另一个采访片段。
So he's going to do some real kind of like off the cuff Rodney Dangerfield impressions, which morphs into a Jeff Foxworthy impression and then Borat and then Jerry Seinfeld and then back to Rodney Dangerfield again. It's a pretty epic talking head. It is. And you know, Jenna, that talking head, that whole Rodney Dangerfield comic riff is not in the shooting draft. It's a whole other talking head.
嗯。所以我不得不想象他们给了史蒂夫一大堆备选方案。他们会那样对我们，对吧？这就是他们选中的那个，因为那不是剧本里的那个。有趣。好吧，我喜欢这个。我也喜欢。我不得不认为史蒂夫即兴发挥了一点。
Huh. So I have to imagine they handed Steve a whole bunch of alts. They would do that to us, right? And this is the one that they picked because that is not the one in the script. Interesting. Well, I liked this one. I did too. And I have to think Steve improvised a little.
我认为它在纸上，但我可以某种程度上看到史蒂夫在做他自己的事。我肯定。当那个采访片段发生时，其他人都在停车场，你知道，他们正准备回家。有一个关于德怀特、安迪、安吉拉三角恋的总结场景。它在拍摄草稿中，没有进入被删减的场景，但安迪和安吉拉走到车前。他们经过德怀特，他正在从Xterra的后窗刮掉一个康奈尔大学的贴纸。
I think it was on the page, but I can sort of see Steve doing his thing. I'm sure. While that talking head was happening, everyone else is in the parking lot, you know, they're heading home. There is a wrap up scene of the Dwight, Andy, Angela love triangle. It's in the shooting draft and it didn't make it to the deleted scenes, but Andy and Angela walked to the car. They passed by Dwight who is scraping off a Cornell sticker from the back window of
安迪说：“再见，老朋友。愿你所有的路都是下坡路，风在你的后挡风玻璃上。”安吉拉说：“安迪。”安迪说：“我不敢相信德怀特会那样对我。他利用了我的善良。”安吉拉说：“他没有利用你。他胜过了你。你被胜过了。”然后他试图把手臂搭在她身上，她把它推开了，她看着德怀特
the XTERRA. And Andy says, goodbye, old friend. May all your roads be downhill and the wind be on your back windshield. And Angela's like, Andy, and Andy says, I can't believe Dwight would do me like that. He took advantage of my kindness and Angela says, he didn't take advantage of you. He bested you. You were bested. And then he tries to put his arm around her and she shoves it away and she looks at Dwight
就像他超级性感一样。哇。是的。好吧，安吉拉，我们应该把这些被删减的场景称为“停车场里的活泼”，因为我知道在帕姆和吉姆的车旁，有一个我们拍摄的场景，我相信在被删减的场景里，吉姆告诉帕姆关于瑞安的真相，以及瑞安对他说了什么，他正瞄准他，可能让他被解雇或让他处于被警告状态，帕姆不接受。
like he's super hot. Wow. Yeah. Well, Angela, we should just call these deleted scenes feisty in the parking lot, because I know that over by Pam and Jim's car, there is a scene that we shot that I believe is in the deleted scenes where Jim tells Pam the truth about Ryan and what Ryan said to him that he's gunning for him to maybe get fired or put him on notice and Pam is not having it.
哦，我把它命名为“帕姆生气了”。是的。萨姆，你得播放那个片段。“嘿，今天到底发生了什么？”“什么意思？”“我是说，我不需要眼镜也能知道什么时候有人让你压力很大。今天发生了什么？”“瑞安正试图摆脱我。”
Oh, I titled it Pam's Pissed. Yeah. And Sam, you got to play that clip. Hey, what really happened today? What do you mean? I mean, I don't need my glasses to know when someone's stressing you out. What happened today? Ryan is trying to get rid of me.
“他今天进来给我一个关于我工作表现的正式警告。”“什么？天哪，他真是个混蛋。这真的让我很生气。我要把他的脸砸烂。我要用一个陈旧的百吉饼把他的脸砸烂。然后我要向他的车扔一块石头。来吧，我们现在就去纽约。”
He came in today to give me an official warning about my job performance. What? God, he's such a creep. That really pisses me off. I'm going to bash his face in. I'm going to bash his face in with a stale bagel. Then I'm going to throw a rock at his car. Come on, we're going to New York right now.
“我开车。如果我不戴眼镜撞到他，我不认为这是犯罪。”“太棒了。天哪，我应该早点告诉你这一切的。真是个混蛋。真是个混蛋。”你能想象如果他们保留了吉姆和帕姆在最开始的性谈话，然后是帕姆说她要向瑞安扔石头或者可能用她的车撞他的场景吗？
I'm driving. If I hit him without my glasses, I don't think it's a crime. Great. God, I should have told you all about this sooner. What a jerk. What a jerk. Can you imagine if they had left in the sex talk between Jim and Pam up at the top and then this scene of Pam saying she's going to throw a rock at Ryan or maybe hit him with
哦，天哪。在拍摄草稿中，它短得多。你只是说：“我要砸烂他的脸”，就这样，你知道吗？但在那个被删减的场景里，帕姆发火了。你不要惹她，女士。我想不是。在他们昨晚度过的那个夜晚之后，不是。
her car? Oh my gosh. In the shooting draft, it was much shorter. You just said, I'm going to smash his face and that was it, you know? But in this deleted scene, Pam is going off. You do not mess with her, Ma'am. I guess not. Not after the night they had last night.
“天堂里的一夜？”是的。哇。好吧，这一集的标签为我们带来了我们需要的所有解决方案。我们回到会议室，迈克尔正在提出一些更伟大的想法，比如夏季圣诞颂歌销售活动。他转向斯坦利：“斯坦利，你觉得怎么样？”斯坦利说：“我觉得这可能是你迄今为止最好的主意。”
The one night in heaven? Yeah. Wowzers. Well, the tag for this episode brings us all the resolution we need. We're back in the conference room, Michael is proposing some more great ideas like a summer Christmas caroling sales event. He throws to Stanley, Stanley, what do you think? Stanley says, I think it might be your best idea yet.
是的。然后菲利斯笑了笑说：“那是我听过的最愚蠢的事情。”迈克尔说：“所有人出去，除了菲利斯。”这就是这一集。这是一个很棒的标签。伙计们，这就是《我结巴了吗》。我不敢相信我要说这个，安吉拉。我们快要到第四季的结尾了。
Yeah. And then Phyllis kind of laughs and says, that's the dumbest thing I've ever heard. Michael says, everybody out except Phyllis. And that's the episode. It's such a great tag. Guys, that was Did I Stutter? I can't believe I'm about to say this, Angela. We are coming up on the end of season four.
我们只有几集了。我知道。昨晚我不得不把一张全新的光盘放进我的DVD播放机。哇。你知道当她不得不放一张新光盘时，情况很严重，伙计们。是的。我正在看第四季的最后一张光盘。过得太快了。
We've just got a few more episodes. I know. Last night I had to put a whole new disc in my DVD player. Wow. You know it's serious when she's got to put a new disc in, guys. Yeah. I'm on my last disc for season four. It's going by so fast.
它飞逝而过。我们下周会带着《招聘会》回来。感谢布伦特·福雷斯特、安吉拉、莱斯利、大卫·贝克。谢谢你们回复关于这一集的短信。也感谢我作为一个数字囤积者，拥有我的拍摄草稿。是的。谢谢你，安吉拉。好了。
It's flying by. We'll be back next week with Job Fair. Thank you to Brent Forrester, Angela, Leslie, David Baker. Thanks for texting us back about this episode. And thanks to me for being a digital hoarder and having my shooting dropped. Yes. Thank you, Angela. All right.
你们这周过得愉快。我们下周见。感谢收听《办公室女士》。《办公室女士》由Earwolf、珍娜·费舍尔和安吉拉·金赛制作。我们的节目由科迪·费舍尔执行制作。我们的制片人是卡西·杰金斯。我们的音响工程师是萨姆·基弗，我们的副制片人是安斯利·布比科。我们的主题曲是克里德·布拉顿的《橡胶树》。
You guys have a great week. We'll see you next week. Thank you for listening to Office Ladies. Office Ladies is produced by Earwolf, Jenna Fisher, and Angela Kinsey. Our show is executive produced by Cody Fisher. Our producer is Cassie Jerkins. Our sound engineer is Sam Kiefer, and our associate producer is Ainsley Bubicoe. Our theme song is Rubber Tree by Creed Bratton.
如需《办公室女士》的无广告版本，请访问StitcherPremium.com。如需Stitcher Premium的一个月免费试用，请使用代码：Office。这一集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子来发表评论。
For ad-free versions of Office Ladies, go to StitcherPremium.com. For a free one-month trial of Stitcher Premium, use code, Office. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
若要收听无广告版的《Office Ladies》，请访问StitcherPremium.com。使用优惠码“Office”即可免费试用Stitcher Premium一个月。本集目前还没有评论。点击逐字稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。